je t'envoie 6 feuilles mortes de sang
Francisco
des poissons volants
une vague le ciel un joli clair de terre
un morceau d'océan une cuillère de
désert
je t'envoie 6 feuilles mortes de sang
Francisco de dauphins une baleine des
haleurs des bateaux une aurore boréale
un typhon une poupée
et les étoiles tombées sur le pont du
bateau
au long de la croisière je ne pense qu'à
toi parmi le pied à terre quand j'ai le
mal de toi
je t'envoie 6 feuilles mortes de sang
Francisco trois soleils et trois lunes
voler à Mexico un récif de corail une
petite sirène comme on en voit danser
minuit sur la scène je t'envoie si
feuilles mortes 200 Francisco le poignet
de neige du
Kilimanjaro une rose de Rio une araignée
du soir et 10000 km de je t'aime en
sautoir j'en ai deux balles ma chère de
ta chair cher en soi et j'ai le mal de
terre danger le mal de toi
je t'envoie 6 feuilles mortes 200
Francisco je t'envoie ces diamants qui
rigolent sur l'eau je t'envoie de
l'amour et caresses la chaîne qui relie
nos deux coeur du navire à la scène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je t'envoie de l'amour les caresses la
chaîne qui relie nos deux cœurs tu la
vire
ah c'est
[Musique]